what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today
i'm here with taylor the sparkle queen
and we are going to be talking about
feminine energy what's up guys um
so the reason i brought taylor on was
because i saw your tic tacs and i've
been watching them for a couple months
things you need to remember if you've
decided to be the feminine energy in the
relationship
the man plans the dates a man will not
fall for you unless he has to put in the
effort
and that starts with taking the
initiative to plan the date and i really
just wanted to learn
more about your journey and so if you
want to give like a little summary of
how
this all started for you so um i've been
on a journey
for the past six months um
to identify what my real root issue was
when it comes to relationships you know
um it was always easy for me to be taken
out on dates and it was always easy for
me to be
approached and hit on in public but none
of these interactions would ever really
turn into anything
and i wanted to figure out why that was
so
i decided to get to the bottom of really
what was going on
yeah so so your issue was like you'd
obviously get like attention from men in
public but none of them
you didn't feel like they wanted to date
you exactly yeah so like either they
wanted like purely a physical
relationship or
we would see each other for a little
while and it wouldn't turn into anything
or it'd be the reverse of like they were
in love with me and i was just like not
attracted to them
really yeah totally what did you like
what were the biggest like problems that
you were having was that like
was there anything that you didn't
encompass in that so um my first biggest
problem was that i was facing
instead of being pursued i was chasing
men and i didn't realize that i was i
was pushing too hard
um i was trying to control the entire
situation
okay um and
yeah so i was chasing men and what do
you mean by chasing just like texting
them first or
yeah testing them first coming up with
the plans for what we would do together
booking hotel rooms for us to stay
together and was this in like your long
because
i'm you're how old you're 30 i'm 30.
yeah so you had like i'm assuming you
had long-term relationships
i've never actually been in a full
committed relationship so that was
another
like that's not been another drive for
me because i've never really been in a
relationship
right i found there's like more people
like that that like haven't had a
long-term relationship
like we only start talking to each other
because i've been posting about it and
like i have other 30 year old women that
are coming to me like me too i've never
been in a relationship and i'm like
why did i have to feel like i was alone
in this before yeah there's a lot of
other people
yeah i didn't know that um so yeah
so like what do you feel like like what
did you do to like help yourself
and like what did you find like look
within and say like this is the reason
like men
aren't asking me to be in relationships
well the first thing i did was i
completely stopped dating
okay entirely like i just took a huge
step back from it i said i didn't want
to date at all i just wanted to focus on
myself
um i realized that i was addicted to
love right and i was like i need a detox
from this like
i'm doing all the wrong things like late
last year i had
instances with like men that wanted to
be with me that wanted casual
opportunities and me
going along with it thinking that it
would get them to want a relationship
and like being in the middle of it and
being miserable because i was like no i
don't want this
um and thinking that you know
the power of sex with me was going to
change them and make them miraculously
want a relationship
like i had to discover that like men
don't work like that no
at all um women and this is why women
think that men connect like this women
connect
with sex yeah right yeah and so we think
that men do too because well
you know we film more for you after
we've had sex obviously you do too when
in fact men feel less for you if they
haven't developed
those feelings for you before you have
sex with them they're going to feel even
less for you after they've said
and i just basically had to come to
terms with that fact what
do you feel like has helped you in terms
of like so i've just been reading like
every book that i can get my hand on so
the first book that i read was called
getting to i do by pat allen
this book was written in the early 90s
so it's been out you know over 30 years
um
it's very very dedicated to
identifying whether you want to be the
masculine or feminine energy in the
relationship
and there's a whole part on if you're
the woman and you want to do the
masculine energy and how to go about it
that's i
for me that is not what i desire because
i always
attract hyper masculine men looking the
way that they
look hyper does that mean like beta no
it would be more masculine than men oh
sorry yeah like a hyper massive man like
a really masculine like
family man like because i love the way
that i carry myself the way that i dress
like really i easily attract like that
type of man
and they approach me because i'm cute
yeah and then i get
like well not anymore because i shifted
my energy but i would get into it with
them and they would
i would start to repel them because i
was doing too much
when you learn um i don't know if i was
the first one that told you that like
the twenty percent of men get eighty
percent of yeah i know you were
but for me that made like a lot of
things like click
okay because i'm like
i would like always be so butt hurt
right that these guys like didn't want
to date me but when you realize like
they get eighty percent of girls like
you kind of take it a lot less
personally
i guess so but then what i thought first
in my head was like i feel like i'm not
only going for the 20
men oh really yeah i feel like i'm going
for
other different types of guys like my
type has been really broad i mean of
course
my type is like typically pretty boy um
so of course that it would definitely be
in the top percent
but but they don't they don't mean uh
they don't mean by looks though oh yeah
they're always exactly like you're
it could be like social status though so
like like so it's like
[Music]
i wish i had this chart because it's
really interesting it goes by like
what age women like the 10 like the
things they value like based on how old
they are
it's like under the age of like 22 it's
like all books like google boy do you
think's cute whatever
and then it's like you get a little
older than social status becomes more
important you get a little older and
then money becomes more important
not everyone obviously every woman likes
psychical religion
some people like politics whatever it is
i've always had my own social status so
like
either i'm naturally running in groups
with men that also have social status
okay or i don't care if they have it or
not because i haven't you can just come
along with me
yeah okay so that hasn't been something
that you what do you so what do you
typically look for i just i want them to
be like tall and like really hot
like that and you know you don't think
that's the top 20 percent of them
because only 15 percent of men are over
six foot only 15
yeah wow i'm tall for a girl i'm yeah i
was like
well i wear heels like all the time how
tall are you
i'm five eight and right now i have on
like a like a two inch heel so it makes
me like [ __ ]
yeah so like they say like that it's
also especially harder for like tall
like successful women no i'm serious
like when they talk about it in the
nanosphere they say like
the taller you are the harder it's going
to be for dating because all the girls
want girls
guys taller than them right and then
like on top of that like if you want
them to be like driven
and successful like that's a very small
like it's a smaller percentage of men
than you think
wow yeah that's why i just work really
hard on myself and try to be really
pretty and dress well yeah
you do so like i'm like
i haven't really noticed that problem
but um
but yeah i mean i guess i don't know for
me that like
that was like so what are you like
how has your dating life been like since
um it's gotten a lot better
um for a little while there and even i
guess still now i say i say no a lot
okay yeah because my standards are
higher i know what i want i have clarity
so like when people approach me and they
don't meet them
it makes it easier to sort of like weed
through people right so it's like
recently i've been saying no more than
i've been saying yes which is like fine
but you know it is what it is um but
the men that are coming into my life i
realized that i've started to weed away
the guys that just want sex
yeah like they i'm not giving off that
energy anymore so like i don't really
get approached by
by that um oh so you think it's like
your energy
oh absolutely oh my god am i pleased
tell me more about this oh my god in my
20s i was girl i could
go into any bar and be like you sir are
coming home with me a really
done deal easy no problem because that
was the energy that i was giving off
okay but i don't like i'm not even that
girl anymore i don't know how
like i've been thinking about it because
it is hot girl suther i don't know
there's a way of
merging that sort of sex giving energy
along with your feminine
like i'm not having sex without
commitment energy because you have to
lure them in
and like the sex is always that is the
thing that's always the main
thing right they say that um men
build like like fall in love through
loyalty
and quality time that's very interesting
yeah that's what that's
according to the nanosphere anyway yeah
you could spend all the time in the
world with them they're not sexually
attracted to you
well yeah they have to like like what
they see yeah but
do you think like you were you given
bad dating advice oh absolutely okay
because i was too and i'm curious like
what do you think's the worst dating
advice
out there for women right now um that
you should be trying to impress men
okay right like so many people tell me
oh well why don't you if you're seeing
somebody why do we tell them these
things
about you like show them all your
amazing qualities
when you start to do that you're leaning
in and you're starting you're starting
to say
how do i get them to like me like what
do i do to impress them and show them
how amazing i am like
when like high key like you don't have
to do any of that right and like one of
my mentors like crystal earrings she
always talks about how like you really
don't have to do anything
huh he's like we as women make it harder
for ourselves because we are
we are doers and we're nurturers and we
want things so
so much and you know we want to you know
be able to like take control of things
but like
realistically like if you want a man who
is going to be a provider for you and
who's going to be more of a masculine
man like
you really should take a couple steps
back and like
let them come in and try to impress you
and if that man is not trying to impress
you then like move on from him like
don't worry about him because he's not
really interested in you
yeah yeah no that's good advice so do
you
so you felt like you were always the one
like chasing the guy pretty much
i wasn't i didn't realize that i was you
know i didn't realize i was chasing it
even when i would think i wasn't chasing
because i held out for a couple weeks
and i never texted first like
i was still drinking because i would be
the one to say well when are we gonna
see each other again
um you know right do you uh
don't question about the manosphere be
really interested in this
i don't know what you make you don't
have to like say would you be okay with
dating a guy that makes less than you
um in the short term sure in the long
term no really
yeah and like not because because
men want to feel like they provide for
you right yeah
so it's like if i'm making more than you
and it comes out like i'm like no i want
to be with a man who's going to be fully
providing for me
okay right you know like the bills he's
got it
you know like all all of those like
we're going out to dinner
we're going on vacation like he's got it
and it's he doesn't even think for me to
come out of my pocket
okay so what is that like how much do
you care
if i asked like how much money would you
need a guy to make to learn like five
hundred thousand dollars
around five hundred thousand oh my gosh
that's so much i mean that's the ideal
like if we're putting it out there okay
yeah yeah i mean
right now i live in l.a and everybody's
an artist so yeah people make what they
make but what's so great about la is
that you never know who someone's going
to be tomorrow
yeah right yeah
oh my gosh 500 but that's so much money
because ultimately i know how much i
want yeah how successful
like i plan on being um
yeah but you don't think that's like
because like i would that's gonna be
hard
because if you want them to be like like
like that's only like two percent of
that
and now it's like really it's like a
very small percentage right now
wow that's i mean if we're going to talk
manifestations and like putting it out
there
yeah but like we'll see who comes to me
okay so like i'm not gonna be like
show me your resume
like no but at the same time i will like
i will not let you take me out
if you make like thirty thousand dollars
oh okay
you're just saying like ideally you'd
like yeah like okay
number i would say 500k right if you're
if you're around the like just under
100k like 100k mark which is like more
averages like younger people in their
like 20s yeah and i know that we can
like grow and build together and
ultimately we'll both be making
you know like that or whatever like
close to you like you know it's an
interesting trait that like i actually
value more than salary and this is
something i'm
curious to see if you value this being
frugal
okay like i'm very no i'm very like
i'm really like cheap i'm not gonna land
cheap i'm not
like i just started out saying you're
like no actually i'm cheap
yeah so like for me like i don't
necessarily
like um so my dad is like very very
successful like he's
like they'd probably like put him in the
top half a percent of earners he did
he did very well like i have nine
siblings who grew up in a very big house
like
and my dad like always taught us the
value of money even though we had like a
lot you know what i'm saying yeah
so he would always stress like how
important it is like not to spend the
money that you have wow
because he he knows people that make a
lot of money but there are so many
people that spend
all their money like the average person
by 30 only has eight thousand dollars in
savings yeah totally
and like it's crazy because like to me
that's
that's that's so bad right you know what
i mean
it's absolutely just because like in
case something happens just because or
like just because the way that you were
raised like
you know um i just want someone that
knows like the value
of money and isn't just like gonna spend
it as soon as you get it because
like when it comes to retirement like
that's really important to say i don't
know i just
i don't know i appreciate you like
sharing this with me i was not born in a
household where we were
raised to save yeah and that's like like
my dad we even though we had
like he's multi-million or whatever we
drove because he would not like spend
the money to fly all
ten eleven of you guys yeah he was like
hell no
we drove to like washington like that's
just like how we were raised
and so it's like interesting to me
because
i like understand like if someone's
saving 20 to 30
of their income sometimes they'll like
beat out the guy like making more
because he doesn't know how to save it
be them out for what like in terms of
like financial like stability
oh sure you're not saying you're not
even being able to like invest money and
then ultimately yeah
so i was just curious is that something
you look forward to or does that not
matter to you
it hasn't been something that i look for
because it hasn't been a value of my own
yeah right i'm just now like teaching
myself to save money
yeah well at 30. as you can talk about
like the statistics absolutely yeah well
it's hard as a woman especially because
like especially in dating like you get
more attention the better you look the
better you
well that stuff's not that hard so as
you talk about being frugal okay you can
be frugal you can be fashionable for
cheap this jacket blocks my mother
from the 90s really i was just curious
so what else do you like look for and
other than like
because there's a lot of yeah there's a
lot of men that watch my channel like
it's like 90
guys so i think that's amazing well it's
funny it's funny because my tech talk is
80
women but my youtube is 90 men wow yeah
because
because i react to mana spirit content
but like i think a lot of them would be
interested to know like what you like
look for in a guy outside of because a
lot of
men like they feel like all women want
is like their money in a second their
job is gone like we're nothing to you
like that's genuinely like
and it's not even like false because
eighty percent of divorces are filed by
women for money for money i knew that
and so that's like
that's why a lot of like men have very
negative
like interactions with women because
they think you're just trying to get
money 80 of men like
like the the way the manosphere talks
about it is they say like
women have no idea how many men we don't
even know exist
i know but that's crazy because i talk
to those men yeah you know like i don't
date them but like i have conversations
with them
right but they're like but imagine
getting like no attention from the
opposite sex
i couldn't okay i also know i have zero
sympathy for men that feel like they
don't get attention from the
opposite sex because i work really hard
on myself yeah right i
exercise you know what i mean i keep my
body looking right i put on makeup i do
i put in the effort right so it's like
these guys like if you're walking around
in cargo shorts and like
you're not in the best outfit like you
can't complain right like it's like you
can't have it both ways
right where i feel bad for them those if
you're born short
what is a short guy supposed to do
what's he supposed to do you're supposed
to get really buff
like you're short no
you're five eight but you dated a guy
had everything you wanted but he's five
six no yeah see he would look awkward in
the pictures
yeah but like he could be making half a
million
have ever really been you know
i don't feel like they're taking
seriously a lot of the time
like what whoa and
um for example like in um
men's like rights when it comes to kids
like oh like if he impregnates the woman
and he wants to keep the kid
yeah like what what percent of men are
awarded like full custody
they're like a very low percent one yeah
five percent and that'd be really well
yeah and like i i've been in like i've
seen situations where the mom's bat [ __ ]
crazy
i'm a child of divorce and like we were
taken away from my father and that was a
blessing
yeah well yeah because like
and every situation is different but
i've just seen situations with like
friends where the mom's like batshit
crazy
like she should not have the kids but
the courts just like award it to her
because she's a woman wow
you know what i'm saying like and like
so hard for the dad to like fight for
that
and then it's like stuff that's not like
mentioned that mother can literally
make up anything about the dad and like
she gets the kids yeah and that happens
like
um i actually asked like my boyfriend
like a lot of like every like 10 like
dads that aren't in the picture he knows
right
how many like would you say
is it because the mom won't let him see
him and how many is because the dad
like and he and i'm not saying he's
right right this could just be his like
work view but he told me like nine times
out of ten because the mom won't let him
see the kids
wow which is something like i didn't
really like know about
i don't know that that could that also
depends on the situation right like um
did you know that every time we
remember a memory we tell it to
ourselves a little bit different
okay right so like every single time you
recall it from your memory
you change the story a little bit to
your favor and that to me is relevant
because
i had a father who just said your mother
wouldn't let me see you
really but it was [ __ ] really yeah
okay this is interesting so
so you know what i mean so to be and so
it's like now it's been 30 years and
like he believes that like that's really
he literally believes that because
that's the story he's been telling
himself
and like but as my mom like recalls it
she'll be like maybe once or twice
because he didn't pay child support but
for your entire lives
for your whole life yeah and then once
we get to a certain age and then once he
like my father emancipated us right
right but then still wanted to pretend
to like be in our lives
so like you can emancipate somebody on
paper so that you don't have to pay for
them anymore
but you don't want to look like a bad
person so we try to like i don't know
what he was thinking or like wanted to
do because he still didn't really try
that hard to like actually be in our
lives like
wow yeah so it's like so they can say
that but
every situation is every situation is
different yeah
i mean i mean i have empathy for people
on both sides
i'm just like from what i've seen a lot
of men
feel like this is just how like what i
understand like the problems that like
men are going through
that men like don't want to get married
anymore because
they are so scared of like women just
taking all their money
no you're laughing but it happens i'm
laughing because i feel like
that is the narrative that is being
pushed out there by
whoever manners we were talking about
and by like that small percentage of men
because they're pissed off that women
don't talk to them
right so then they don't they're not
getting any chicks so then they come out
and they're like
well we don't want to be married anyway
and it's like
no that's true no that's true there's a
lot of guys that are just mad that girls
girls like won't talk to them like
that's 100 and so for me
like i was running into issues with my
relationship so i decided to completely
change my
energy right right and these dudes where
they decided to complain
is that actually changing themselves or
doing anything about the problem i don't
have something for them
some of them do and i lost 20 pounds i'm
like i want to open my
my dating opportunity up to everybody
actually i need to show you oh now i
really want to react to a video
because if i showed you this video i'm
really curious to see what you'd say
okay yeah okay